all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts give
my thoughts over morning coffee first
things first guys I have not had coffee
in 2 weeks two weeks I don't know how I
did it because I thought it would be
impossible to do but one day I just said
I'm just going to stop drinking it and I
haven't I haven't drank it ever since
I'm like wow what a
day uh second thing I know I have a gap
in between my teeth right now I know
everyone's goingon to comment that
um and I'm going to have it for like
three weeks I've basically had like
composite bonding between my teeth for
like I don't know a long time but I
didn't like the last time they did it
and I finally have time now to fix it so
there I have to like wait until I get
back though for the second appointment
so you know anyways um couple
announcements we're considering moving
so we might be moving soon but I know
I've been saying that for a while so I
won't even get you guys' I won't even
get you guys's hopes up um second we
have new show schedule with um Christine
Nazarene and Troy so they're all going
to be doing their own shows with the
network so if you haven't subscribed to
them make sure you guys go do that um
and third of
all we have a new sponsor um that's
coming
soon um it's his name is Dr Patrick
Flynn with the Wellness Way and he's
really awesome I've been to like his
facilities in Wisconsin
um and he works with women on like
fixing their hormones so I know I've
talked to you guys that about like
having some issues with my hormones and
really trying to fix them um and part of
it I kind of want to document like the
stuff I'm doing to like fix that and I
know one of them is like I have to eat a
certain amount of protein every day so
I'm like getting up on stakes and stuff
um anyway so I don't know if I'll do
that in a second Channel or on this one
I might make a second channel for it
we'll see um
anyways
so what I actually wanted to talk about
today now that I get through my two
minutes of announcements is I was
thinking about how we were never going
back to the
1950s and
tradcons it's so interesting cuz I I saw
this clip of Charlie Kirk and he said
that you should marry Young
young find a woman men marry
young and have a bunch of
babies and I thought to
myself are these commentators out of
touch or
pandering like I I don't know is it cuz
Charlie I'm like you realize you were
dating not that long ago you know these
women aren't trying to get married at 18
anymore you know they're not traditional
and I thought to myself I just and he
was saying it's like because of the
population collapse or whatever and and
Charlie Kirk got married at 27 so he
spent 10 years you know building himself
up and then he got married and in a
modern day when women all want the top
guy that makes way more sense for
men that makes way more sense because
women don't want to build a in
now I I know they used to do that like
50 years ago I know maybe you can go out
into the country and like
find someone I'm sure but guys even the
country women are getting a bit
corrupted they're still going to college
in the cities they're moving to the
cities
like and these Trends aren't going to
stop and I don't say this in a happy way
I was thinking about
this and I was thinking about how in the
The Last 5 Years I am so much more used
to seeing naked
women it's it's so bad like I don't even
think twice about it um like if I see a
girl half naked it's like I'm just used
to it you go to the beach and there's
thongs everywhere you're just used to
it and the
future is going to
be more hookers like it's just going to
be more sex workers it's going to be
more promiscuity it's going to be less
marriage and it's not what I want right
this isn't what Pearl wants and that's
what they always confuse it they'll
always think I'm saying oh well men
should just sleep
around and and it's interesting one CR
critique I hear is that me like men
should not sleep with so many women
that's wrong but women don't tend to
want a guy unless he's slpt
around um
and you can kind of hear it in a guy's
voice when he hasn't because he has no
experience with women he doesn't know
how to call out his girl when she's
acting up he doesn't know how to stand
up to her he doesn't know how to lead
the relationship and men can really only
get that through experience now I'm not
saying that it's morally
correct but these are kind of the new
tools that men have to use to adapt so
you
know now we have to think in
the average chick isn't a virgin okay
like these don't really exist anymore
I've interviewed over a thousand women I
think I found maybe five and one I
believe you know what I mean like okay
you're going to tell these guys and
they'll say go to church and I I I
thought about when I was super like like
when I would I I was really involved in
this church in Milwaukee for like 2
three
years I mean I guess there was one
virgin ch chick but I mean she was picky
as all hell I mean as she should be but
should the average guy like wait around
for
that so I just kind of was thinking to
myself that and I think this is
sometimes where Rolo gets
mad
um I know he's he's not my biggest fan I
love him though I'm such a fan but you
know
anyways
because it's like the tradcons can come
in and say get married young but it's
only virtue signaling because there's no
women to marry Sorry Charlie like I'm
not
I'm I I'm not saying
that they don't exist at all but the
odds of the average guy finding one it's
just kind of a needle in the in a hay
stack you know and there's research
that's been done that said when you take
out sex work overweight too promiscuous
tattoos all that stuff only 5% of women
are
marriageable I mean that's not so it's
like almost like saying get married
young is like virtue signaling or men
don't sleep around it's kind of virtual
signaling now I understand it's like
it's tough because if you give this
argument it sounds like you're going
against
God
um and you can't win whenever someone
brings religion into it you just can't
win it's like it's so annoying because
the high value man thing I tried to have
a conversation around
that and what'll happen is you'll
say all right high value men you have to
make this much amount of money you have
to be wanted by other women you have to
be in shape like whatever right and then
the religious people will come in and
say oh but a real high value man a real
high value man has a relationship with
God well Diane how do we measure that
like which God like and then it just
goes down a rabbit hole okay but it's
interesting because the Trap consons
will come in and say give these women
traditional treatment treat them
traditional but traditional women don't
exist even even the most pure women that
I've met on the podcast get way more
attention than any woman did in the 19
20s 30s 40s and 50s and no matter how
nice of a chick you are that still
changes you so marriage is going to get
older and older people are going to keep
getting married and having kids older um
I'm not saying that's what's right but
it's going to be what happens and so now
we're in a time period where the average
age of first marriage is
30 and you know it's also
interesting these guys never know their
wives from childhood I mean occasionally
I think Michael nolles did but they
still broke up in college I'm like red
flag red
flag you know what I mean like I thought
to I thought to myself about this these
guys will all talk about the good women
that they found but there's no verifying
the women's stories I
mean most of them met them in their 20s
they were in their 20s nothing wrong
with that but are is your chick really
different than all the other
chicks I I doubt it you know so it's
almost like virtue signaling
because what they'll do and I guess I've
probably done this too is say all right
I'll give you an example where I've done
it and I didn't mean it like I didn't
mean it to Virtue signal but when you
think about it if I say guys we should
ban oh if I say guys we should okay
if I say guys we should ban only fans
okay we need to ban it well it's not
getting banned um and sex work is going
to
continue to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and what why is this pH not
and what are we going to do about it and
even the them saying okay well a man
should provide well how is the guy going
to provide when women are taking their
jobs the guys are like I'm trying but
they keep giving you guys our
jobs and then the women vote for higher
and higher
taxes so now because of what we've voted
for and what we have chosen as women now
I know not every woman's chos this I
didn't choose it it was the women before
us but they've told men for 50 years we
don't need
them we've taken their jobs we voted for
higher and higher taxes so now I mean
the average family is going to need two
parents working now I could virtue
signal right when I have kids I'll stay
with
them but most people Arn in my financial
position and this is just me being
honest so now what am I going to I going
to do to the average
person like the average person doesn't
really have the choices that I have so
it's kind of virtue signaling when these
guys come up and they're always
podcasters and I'm like you realize
there's coal miners there's Factory
workers like men with 10 times harder
jobs than you you're just a talker we're
I'm just a
talker we have amazing jobs like this is
amazing to have a family in DED you know
what I mean like this is the best job
ever
but you know it doesn't really resonate
with like Middle
America a and the average Joe in America
they're working a job that's a normal
job and we need those jobs to run and do
the things we
do um so you kind of just have to make
tools going forward so what the guys
will do in the red pill and it's tough
cuz I don't know what to label myself
because because I do talk about a lot of
like red pill
stuff but I
mean I mean there's guys that have been
doing it for 20 years and they're really
really smart guy
anyways
so I think to myself I think to
myself the sleeping around is just a
reaction because they don't know how to
tell the difference between a good girl
and a bad girl they don't know how to
tell the difference between a girl
that's making them wait just to mess
with them and extract resources from
them versus a girl that's genuine about
it
um so that's why myin has stuff like
sleep with a girl on a first date or get
rid of her it's not because he's this
evil guy or whatever he just wants to
screw I mean I'm sure he does like every
guy but it it's because this is a tool
moving forward because of the mess that
we
created and it's funny because instead
of pointing the figure finger at the
women and saying hey why are you guys L
why are you ladies sleeping with 5% of
men they point the finger at the men for
sleeping with them when most men can't
even do
it and the question is it's not 1950s
anymore the same way it's not Medieval
Times anymore I can't cosplay into
medieval times so what do we do moving
forward and I don't really have the
answers I don't know I don't know if you
can outbreed the competition because I
mean I have a cousin that homeschooled
his kids and half of them came out
liberal and that's kind of similar to
the raid in my family that went to I
mean Catholic school but
still I mean it's still like 50 you
know so I I don't really know what the
answer is but I I think men it's not
really going to change till men take
back power and I don't see that
happening any time soon I see more women
getting into positions of
power um so it's kind of like well until
that happens what what do you
do I don't know but let me know what you
think in the comments um I might
actually make a second channel for over
break when I go home
because I'm really trying to fix my
hormones because I have issues so
anyways like the video on your way out
guys subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time